in 1924 paul amadeus dinock had been
teaching the german language in greece
dying of tuberculosis he wanted to
return home to switzerland before he
left he gave hundreds of pages of
handwritten notes to his favorite
language student georgios papahatsis
dinock thought translating his notes
would help papahatsus in his study of
the german language they said goodbye
never saw each other again papahatsus
began translating the pages there were
whole passages about a coming nuclear
war colonizing mars and a global
government sections about flying
vehicles holographic technology and
contact with alien life
poppahotsis thought it was a science
fiction novel but as more and more the
text was revealed papahatsus was shocked
at what he discovered this wasn't a
novel at all this was actually dienoch's
personal diary dinock wrote about how he
went into a coma and woke up two
thousand years in the future
it seems that paul amadeus dinock had
experienced some kind of time slip that
caused him to fall asleep in the year
1921 and wake up in the year 3906
he spent a whole year in the future and
he wrote down everything he saw
this is his story
[Music]
it's may 1921. paul dinock is teaching
his college language class when he
starts to feel dizzy he has a history of
illness and eventually ends up
hospitalized he develops a terrible
fever and for the next few hours he's in
and out of consciousness he perceives
different men and women gathering around
him but he's too weak to communicate
when he finally wakes up his hospital
room is different people are dressed in
unfamiliar clothing and they're speaking
a strange language being a language
teacher he recognizes a few words from
english and swedish adenoc tries to
communicate but nobody can understand
him one of the doctors recognizes his
language the doctor tries his best to
communicate in broken german he tells
dnoc his name is actually andreas
northam a famous physics professor who
had an accident now dinock says he has
no idea who andreas northam is but he's
shown a mirror and he sees a stranger's
face looking back at him now dinock
becomes visibly upset and starts sobbing
he thinks he's dead or worse gone crazy
he cries that he's just a simple
language teacher from switzerland and
has no idea what's happening to him
the doctors seem to react to the word
switzerland and someone asks him what
year it is dinox says it's 1922.
a hush falls over the room after a few
seconds the older physician steps
forward and tells deenock but the ear is
actually 3906 now dinock doesn't believe
it the blinds on his windows are opened
and he sees buildings reaching through
the clouds vehicles that seem to defy
gravity buzz quickly past his window
suddenly overwhelmed he blacks out
dinock is watched carefully for three
days but he eventually recovers enough
to walk and he describes walls made of
crystal that give you a panoramic view
of the landscape objects are made of
pastel colored glowing metal that's warm
to the touch and he's led through a
corridor to a large room here he meets
two older men in white robes and at
first dinock thinks they're actually
priests or kings but they're actually
called electors with an eye these are
like elder wise men now up until this
time doc's doctors didn't believe he was
from the past they thought he was
suffering from some kind of brain trauma
but after questioning him for a while
the electors do believe him they have
knowledge of a rare psychic phenomenon
that they called a consciousness shift
where someone's mind or soul could be
transported into somebody else's body
and they think that's what happened to
dinock when andreas northam whose body
was being occupied by dinoc was injured
in an accident he was clinically dead
for 15 minutes doctors dropped the
temperature of his brain and they were
able to restart his heart it was at that
point the electors believed that this
personality shift occurred and the mind
of paul dinock was transferred into the
body of andreas northam two thousand
years in the future how does your
consciousness get beamed into the future
well enoch wonders about this too and he
asked the electors about it and they say
that time isn't linear that everyone's
consciousness exists all the time
everywhere you know even though this is
a rare event it is something that's
known to happen it's at this point that
a man named stefan is summoned now
stefan had been a close friend of
andreas northam and the electors decide
that only stefan and his doctors would
know his true identity to everyone else
paul dinock would be andreas northam and
enoch would assume his life now the
electors believe that if stefan could
help andreas northam regain his memories
that the personality shift could be
reversed and dinock would be sent back
to his own time so
stefan agrees to visit dinoc every day
to teach him about modern society but
dinock is mostly interested about what
happened in the past
even though the doctors in
60 understood the psychic personality
shift there was one thing that puzzled
them back in the 1920s dnoc was
suffering from something called
encephalitis lethargica sometimes called
sleeping sickness and people with this
disease have difficulty speaking moving
staying awake in the 1920s there was
actually an epidemic of encephalitis
lethargica that affected over a million
people around the world but even though
dinock had been living in the future for
a full two weeks he never slept he would
stay awake throughout the night reading
books learning the new language but he
never felt tired and never actually fell
asleep he spent a lot of time using a
new piece of technology called oregon
schwager now up until now the most
modern learning device dnoc ever
encountered was a book but he describes
the regan schwager as a handheld device
with moving three-dimensional images
that glow in the dark with sound music
and narration
like an ipad kinda yeah and denox
doctors encouraged him to learn anything
he wanted about the past but they did
not let him study the 20th century they
didn't want him to have knowledge about
any historical event that he might be
able to change so what did he learn well
the years 2000 through 2300 are the most
difficult for the human race
overpopulation and regional conflict are
the biggest problems we face
in 2204 we finally colonized mars over
60 years the population on mars grows to
20 million people but
in 2265 there was some kind of
planet-wide catastrophe like a large
impact event that wiped out the entire
colony and we never tried again in 2309
there was a medium-scale nuclear war
that devastated most of europe only the
baltic and scandinavian countries
survived which is presumably why their
language is an english scandinavian
hybrid now this war would be global and
last for 80 years and most of the human
population would be wiped out in 2396 a
new world government called a redstot
was established and this ends the
ancient period of history and marks the
beginning of modern history oh no what
one world government
yep when the red stop was formed in 2396
it was a one world government designed
to end the global war and it was a
government like we'd recognize today
corrupt pretty much it was run by the
wealthy and powerful and countries
around the world still had strong local
nationalism so they resisted the new
government for about 200 years
eventually citizens stopped electing
politicians and businessmen instead the
higher offices were held by scientists
philosophers and humanitarians
what that actually makes sense it does
and over the next 300 years society
starts to reform in 2823 a world leader
named torahild proposed a new economic
system and this system is not based on
global scarcity like our system instead
the system is based on global adequacy
it is at this point that people start
working for the greater good
initially they work for 40 years of
their life in their chosen field and
after that they retire all of their
material needs are met by the global
community now as time goes on technology
and automation progresses so much that
when paul dinock arrives people work
only two years of their life they're
educated through their childhood and at
age 17 they enter the workforce they
work very hard for about two years and
then they retire able to pursue any type
of life they want they work for two
years that's it that's it because in
3906 all material needs are met food
shelter clothing education even
entertainment and money as we know it
isn't used anymore instead value is
placed in art and science you could
absolutely pursue a career if you wanted
like andreas northam was a physicist but
you didn't have to work if you wanted to
live a life of leisure as long as you
completed your two years of service you
could do that sounds to me like some
hippie star trek socialite paradise bull
i admit it does kind of sound like that
you know socialism and communism never
work right i know that which is an
interesting twist to the story let me
ask you why doesn't socialism work
because no matter how good most people
are there's always selfish jerks who
want more that's right human nature gets
in the way but by the year 3906 we're
not human anymore wait wait what at
least we're not human as we think of it
we evolve into something else
paul dinock talks of a phenomenon that
starts to happen to people around the
year three thousand it's called the
needlework needlework niebelwerk what i
say in the future the human brain
structure evolves and a new sense organ
is developed this gives people the
ability to perceive a new plane of
existence and access to vast spiritual
knowledge they call this ability over
sin sons or supervision and it gave
people a new cognitive ability instant
enlightenment sounds pretty good well
you would think this new sense gave
people feelings of incredible happiness
and spiritual peace and it's described
as divine joy acceptance of death a
disregard for all worldly things
and this feeling came all rushing at
once people freaked out didn't they they
did and everyone who experienced the
needlework died they died with looks of
ecstasy on their faces but they were so
overwhelmed that they couldn't survive
the event until
33.82 on september 6th of that year a 76
year old man named alexis volky was hit
with the navel work needlework
niebelwerk what'd i say
but he survived
and from then on everyone survived the
nibel work eventually the switching on
of this new perception was a common
process in everyone's life homo sapiens
then gave way to a new species of human
homo occidentalis novus or new western
man so in the future human nature itself
changes present humans are hardwired for
survival competition and success even at
the expense of others so this utopian
vision of the future just wouldn't work
today but what if you can change the
actual wiring of the human brain itself
in 3906 there were hardly any laws they
weren't needed anymore people actually
worked for the common good because
that's how they're evolved selfishness
is a concept that is studied as an
archaic remnant of a less evolved
species people in 3906 can't even
imagine themselves acting like we do
today now paul dinock finds the future
people very strange he says they act
like carefree children but you have to
admit
there's a part of you maybe even a large
part that would like to go back to some
moment in your childhood where all your
needs were met where you had no fear no
envy no anxiety as denox friend stefan
says all these things that you view as
strange who is to say that they are
childish instead of divine
interesting point
but dinock wonders how would these
people survive an outside threat like
contact with aliens well stefan says
they've already been contacted many
times and it turned out fine
humans in the future are aware of
intelligent beings living in the solar
system and around the galaxy but they
aren't interested in communication with
us instead they prefer to study us from
a distance but stefan does admit they
have intervened with the human race on a
few occasions like when our species was
close to self-imposed extinction and
enoch learns that these extraterrestrial
beings experience their own kind of
enlightenment needlework neighborwork
what i say
so aliens leave us alone to walk our own
path
when paul dinock was a young man he fell
in love with a girl from his village
named anna
though anna felt the same her family
wanted her to marry someone else now
during one of their last moments
together they were sitting on a hill
surrounded by blossoming wind flowers
which are white buttercups now paul
wanted this day to last forever because
he knew he was losing her so finally she
said enough for today let's go back and
paul said promise me that i will see you
again and she said she promised and the
next time we're here i'll make a wreath
of wind flowers for you to place upon my
head now paul never did see her again
and this was something that tormented
him his entire life he would constantly
pray for signs of anna's eternal love
for him but those signs never came okay
cute story but
where are we going with this let's get
back to the crazy stuff well having
spent a year with the people in 3906
d-noc developed a relationship with a
woman named sylvia they decided to go
for a day trip they traveled in what
deena called avigiosa which was a flying
vehicle that could take you anywhere on
earth almost instantly he decided he
wanted to visit his old village though
sylvia didn't know that's where they
were going so they spent the day talking
and exploring eventually ending up on
that same hill where paul and anna were
all those years ago now wind flowers
were also blossoming that day and while
they sat and talked sylvia made a wreath
of wind flowers she then looked at paul
dinock and said enough for today let's
go back she hands him the reef and asks
him to place it upon her head
reincarnation yes dinock feels like he's
hit by lightning he sees this as the
sign he's been praying for his entire
life later he reflects on the day with
stefan who reminds him that time isn't
linear stefan believes sylvia is the
reincarnated soul of anna who 2000 years
later fulfills her promise that night
paul dinock feels his eyes getting heavy
and he wonders if he'll finally be able
to sleep at night from now on and his
last thought is how much he missed this
feeling finally andreas northam falls
asleep for the first time in a year and
back in 1922 paul dinock awakens from a
year-long coma
[Music]
the story of paul amadeus dinock is such
a good one but what really happened to
him was his story real was it a hoax a
money grab
well there are a couple of options the
first is that he was telling the truth
that he really had a paranormal
experience that sent him 2 000 years
into the future and if you read the
entire book it seems plausible it's over
300 pages and it's full of details there
are hundreds of names places dates dnoc
talks about future technology like
cryonics the internet flying vehicles
teleporters and even something that
sounds like a holodeck i can't come
close to covering everything here but
i'll link to the book if you want to
check it out if you're a kindle
unlimited subscriber no sponsor it's
actually free to read the second option
is that while in his coma paul dinock
experienced what he thought was reality
but was nothing more than vivid dreams
you could dream in a coma well it
depends on the illness and injury of the
brain but people definitely can and do
and if he was dreaming for a year that's
plenty of time to create a richly
detailed vision of the future world but
there's one more theory we have to
consider and it's the theory that i
believe
it's that paul amadeus dinock never
existed
even though the story of paul dinock is
not that well known it's been covered in
a few blogs and podcasts and videos and
in all of them the same photo of paul is
used it's the photo i used in the
thumbnail it's this one here but what's
never mentioned
that this is actually the mugshot of
daniel towhill who was arrested for
theft in new zealand in 1908. also paul
dinock lived in zurich in the 1920s
that's not that long ago the city has
records of every citizen living in the
city at that time as does the city of
athens where dinock was supposed to be
teaching but there are no records of
anyone by this name not even close now
georgia's papahatsis the translator and
publisher of the story says he tried to
find enoch years later but couldn't he
attributed this to the fact that dinock
fought for germany during world war one
and actually changed his name before
moving to neutral switzerland so we
don't know what his real name is yeah
it's convenient well what's even more
convenient is that the original
handwritten diary is gone papa hatsu
said that while living in greece during
the war his house was searched by the
greek military and because the notes
were in german the soldiers seized them
and never gave them back yeah sounds
fishy it does and others have noted the
similarity of this story to a story
written by h.p lovecraft called the
shadow out of time lovecraft's story is
written in the first person like a diary
and the protagonist goes into a coma and
wakes up at a different time
well deenock woke up in the future and
lovecraft's hero wakes up in the past
still there are similarities and the
shadow out of time was published in 1936
so if the story was inspired by
lovecraft then there's no way it was
written by dinock in the 1920s so this
greek dude read a hoax i don't think so
giorgio's papahatsis was a highly
respected law professor and intellectual
he even served as a jurist on greece's
council of state that was like their
supreme court so this was a serious guy
he was very interested in administrative
law social studies and humanities and
these are the themes we see in paul
dinock's diary it's likely that the book
was written as an intellectual exercise
and exploration of human spirituality
and papahasis added the sci-fi twist and
the love story as literary devices now
he probably didn't mean for anyone to
take it seriously as something that
actually happened but there's no way to
know for sure i mean this is the age of
the internet and if you write a story
about a time-traveling coma patient
people are going to believe it
i certainly wanted to
[Music]
thanks so much for hanging out with us
today my name is aj that's hecklefish
this has been the y-files if you had fun
or learned anything do me a favor and
comment subscribe like share all that
stuff it really helps us out until next
time be safe be kind and know that you
are appreciated
do you hear my stomach growl
now
we're keeping it
[Music]
you